thank you and I'll open by saying the
slides are all available online I'll
give you the link at the end take
pictures if you like but exactly
verbatim and it's it's a github repo so
it's versions you don't have to worry
about it
do PRS if you'd like I don't think I'll
accept them but you can try cool so
hello my name is Brendan hugger you
might have seen me bouncing around a
little bit I work for Capital One and
I'm also very happy to be one of the
organizers for this event so if
anything's going really really poorly
please send me an email and let me know
because it's a good learning experience
for us this is kind of one of the first
events like this that we've ever thrown
today I'll be talking about class and
balance and adversaries before we type
too into it let's take it back and take
a step back and really scope the talk
this being a conference I figured xkcd
is appropriate there's this guy playing
some sort of a very old video game he
says man I suck at this game can you
give me some pointers at trying to be
helpful
gives him some pointers and they're not
very helpful and I've been to a lot of
data science talks like this where you
know you talk about class and balance
your adversaries they're very weird
processes and people say like yeah these
problems exist come by our product and
they're not very helpful or they'll go
super super deep in a detail and give
you the literal pointers and they're not
helpful either in this talk I hope to
sort of bridge those two and say well I
sit on a team that deals with these
kinds of problems pretty often
there's no good description of the
techniques that you should look at as a
first pastor things that we've found to
be really helpful so I'd like to give a
talk that kind of bridges those two and
hopefully is pretty practical and usable
for everybody in the room with that let
me give you a bit of context as to Who I
am and why you should care I am a member
of vault 8 Alternaria is dead the data
intelligence lab at Capital One we're an
integrated team of data scientists data
engineers DevOps software engineer
databases really holistic team that
solves the entire problem mimsy is you
can drop us into very challenging
domains and we can solve them pretty
well and then handoff to another team
who can do the work that is necessary to
follow up and as a holistic approach we
try not only to solve the problem
but solve it entirely so it's not like
we created this model in Python
good luck DevOps we build the entire
thing and that's pretty cool and this is
gonna be the one shameless plug in the
talk we're also hiring so if that
interests you come find me and shameless
plug cool so with that we can get into
the actual talk and three main sections
these are just techniques that I've
found to be helpful and I think other
people should definitely look at the the
three sections are sampling so
understanding kind of how you look at
your data and change your observation
rate and then we go into future
engineering add a little bit more
information they're algorithms are able
to grab on to and finally modeling how
you can be smart about choosing
algorithms that do really well anytime
you have class imbalance and adversaries
this is a good time to stop and say a
little bit like class and Bella's and
adversaries that's very abstract what
does that mean it's really any case
where you have usually a minority group
that's trying to subvert this system
this happens all the time the classic
example of course is spam where you have
a very small percentage of users who are
spending a large volume of emails in a
way that really the system is designed
for and your idea here is well it's very
small number of total observations to
capture but we'd like to flag them in
some way this occurs across many many
domains cool so we'll dive in with that
and just one last housekeeping
announcement for the flow of the talk
you can hold your questions towards the
end we should have about 10 or 15
minutes for questions so ample time to
cover them there so up first is sampling
these are a couple of sampling
techniques that I've found to be helpful
and some of them are pretty intuitive
but it's worth saying anyways the first
is observation waiting you should be
doing and hopefully you should be using
a package that supports observation
waiting or affecting the cost function
directly and this really is mostly a
trend time at predict time it's pretty
hard to do effectively but weights
include uniform weight which is what
most people do where you just count all
observations the same there's
observation age which is kind of a
staleness so let's say that you're
looking at the spam domain if there's a
weird kind of spam that was happening a
year ago you don't want to exclude if
your model because you could see a
resurgence but you don't want to say you
know this kind of spam from a year ago
is worth exactly as much as the spam
today
because it's old it's no longer common
and whoever your adversary is moving
over quickly and then there's also
random downsampling which is the most
common technique and it comes from more
of a cisco practice but fortunately can
lose a lot of information from a very
particular about how you down sample
it's a look at observational waiting so
if we look at the blue line that's kind
of uniform if we have the x-axis being
the time in days or months or years or
whatever your sort of domain dictates
and the y-axis being your weight
assigned to each observation I've
standardized to one here because you can
kind of show that it normalizes that up
to a coefficient but that's another
story so the blue line would be if you
just counted everything up to 55 days
the same that works a lot of people do
it it's not awful the more interesting
one is the tang weight the orange line
which says all right the observations
from today worth one and then we've
slowly decay off and I've chosen a curve
here that looks pretty but normally it
would be quite this steep there's also a
really cool technique called smote
synthetic minority over a sampling
technique and there'll be a
visualization in just a second but this
is a quick overview the goal is to
reduce the effect of class imbalance so
you really do two things usually you'll
have a majority case and a minority case
for the majority case you'll down sample
with some probability so they start
pulling observations as necessary for
the minority case you create synthetic
observations notice if you take the
observations you had already and you
just double them or copy and paste them
that's pretty much equivalent is
changing the observation way to two and
you're not really adding new information
you're just changing the way that your
algorithm will think about the
information has already so how to
include new information there's just a
couple of pretty simple steps but it
basically comes down to interpolating
from your existing data
so first is you'll subset to exclusively
the minority case well that's 0 I guess
number one is you'll pick a random point
number two you'll select a neighbor and
you can use K nearest neighbors you can
just like random points and third is you
create a new point and this isn't
totally interpolation because basically
between the two points you decide on
some distance between the two and use
that distance and this doesn't entirely
respect the underlying distributions but
heuristic lis it's been shown to add a
lot of value and also you can get new
interesting observations that are
similar to existing observations
this helps add some meat the your
algorithms can grab on to so just quick
recap of sampling there's two major
techniques that I've mentioned
observation waiting pretty intuitive but
we're saying anyways in smoke sampling
which is pretty interesting and I've
found to be pretty useful quick sidenote
I forgot to mention earlier so if you
look on the bottom the slides we pull it
up I've tried to link to the seminal
paper for most of these works and in
some cases a seminal paper and a
framework that does it so if you want to
actually look into these kinds of things
you don't have to Google madly yeah you
probably can't read that this is just
for if you download them later
up next or features these are
interesting features you can add on to
your data set usually increasing the
width of your data sets sometimes
actually decreasing just give your
algorithms something different to grab
on to
the first is outlier detection so this
is really a score of how unusual an
observation is for your system Trane's
to kind of look for things that are
similar to what it's seen before and
there's two main ways of doing this
using PCA and neural networks and the
idea here is that you train some
underlying system to recreate
observations that I've seen before so a
few subsets and known good observations
and train this system it gets to be
really really efficient at recreating
the input vector for good observations
and then you can take the distance
between the output in the input and it
gives you kind of an outlier score and
the distance metric you cannot kind of
have your choice depending on the space
you're in but it is a pretty effective
way of saying okay my system is good at
recreating known good observations if I
give it a bad observation it's gonna
really suck at recreating it so there
should be a large distance between the
input and the output to make that a
little clearer here's the observation
the key here is and I've done this with
neural networks it's pretty equivalent
of PCA usually I have a squeeze point if
you had a neural network that was the
same number of notes all the way down it
would just pass the information along
not very interesting but by fortunately
this dimensionality reduction in the
middle of the neural network or using
PCA with a lower number of components
you force it to take the most
interesting or observable bit of
information and then extrapolate back
out which gives you a pretty good
distance metric again seminal paper
and label propagation this is a network
based approach that allows you to
identify networks of bad actors to say
like oh we have this email address
that's ending we know it's bad at
sending out spam and there's this
related email address that's sending
some of the same people you know
heuristic lis we can say well what is
the overlap where's the card distance we
can kind of guess what their network
overlay might look like but it's better
to have more of a scientific approach
and this is kind of a better way of
thinking about it so the idea is that
you create a graph where the nodes are
actors the edges are Association
strength number of shared users number
to the intersection divided by the total
number of users that each of them has
whatever edge weight you'd like and then
you label some of the nodes the
interesting thing here is you don't have
to label all of the nodes you can label
1 percent 3 percent 5 percent 50 percent
if you'd like so you can label 1 percent
as good actors 5 percent as bad actors
and then sort of relax those labels
through the system I've taken bad actors
kind of literally here so here the edge
weights are the number of movies that
two actors have been in together based
on a very cursory IMDB search so please
don't hold me to this and a couple of
actors that I've labeled is getting bad
you may label them differently so if two
of these actors share many movies this
technique would likely say well one of
them is labeled as bad the other one has
been in most of the same movies maybe
they're both bad actors with some high
probability they'll both have the same
label another interesting technique that
kind of goes in the opposite direction
it actually reduced the amount
information as low ranked models and
this is a generalization of PCA that
works really well if you have
categoricals
sometimes if you have text and the goal
here is to reduce dimensionality if with
datasets with many variables if you have
a high correlation high covariance
things like that and then you can
actually step back and add remove the
uninteresting information so that if you
have a tree based method which is really
great for class imbalance it doesn't get
lost in very very similar variables and
it mostly models and you'd mostly then
model on the underlying components
latent factors
for those who are unfamiliar with PCA
and I keep mentioning it here's kind of
the underlying idea you have an X into y
they're highly correlated so rather than
using that directly you might run PCA
get these two components and that's a
new basis in which you can describe it
so you think it's sort of rotating the
whole picture and you notice well most
of the information was along one of the
axes the positive correlation axis maybe
we'll just use that one and remove this
sort of a thatíll axis which is matting
a whole lot of information final
interesting technique that we've used is
LD a topic modeling this is really great
for domains where you have the concept
of a user or user profile this is
actually a technique that's stolen from
natural language processing and the idea
here is to reduce the dimensionality for
a variable with many levels so if you
have many different flags that people
use for different kinds of emails or
something like that maybe you don't we
use the flags directly but you want to
capture something and I won't go too
much into technique it's pretty
complicated
again seminal paper read it it's pretty
good it's pretty complicated but the
idea is to identify bags of words that
are maximally separated so different
topics that are very well separated and
then identify which this topics the
particular document you're looking at
goes to where that document is a user
profile so if you take all the email
tags and create a document from that or
actual text you're processing again
here's a picture that kind of looks at
it this is from a really great paper
describing this concept but it's a
biology paper that has a couple of
computational terms in it a couple of
Neurobiology terms a couple of biology
terms and from that you can kind of see
that it's mostly about the yellow I
believe yellow and blue topics the paper
is kind of truncated but from that you
could kind of group everything together
say you know this is the main theme of
the document we're just gonna use that
theme and not all the underlying text
cool so just to recap for futures we've
got outlyer detection which is a good
way of understanding when an observation
is unlike the known good observations
label propagation which helps you
identify networks of good actors and bad
actors sometimes literally glr m which
is generalized PCI which helps remove
cases where you have very high
correlation your data set which can
confuse a lot of the algorithms that are
very good for class and balance and LD a
topic modeling which can help you
Douce dimensionality of some spaces if
you have user profiles or that kind of a
concept and finally we have modeling
these are just a cursory overview you
could go really really deep here but I'm
hope we can flush out more of this
section in the Q&A so first this grid
search again pretty intuitive if you're
at PI data you've probably used SK learn
at some point and you're probably a big
fan of the pipeline and grid search
modules in there but it's worth
mentioning because everybody should do
it not everybody does also neural
networks are really great for class
imbalance unfortunately their way out of
the scope of this talk that would
probably take like a to talk session to
get a good intro to but there are many
others that are available which OC other
talks just Google neural networks and
class and balance and there's also
ensemble modeling which does really well
and this is a pretty cool technique
where if you have different kinds of
class and balance or different kinds of
bad actors say SPM is really good at
catching one kind of spam and random
forest is really great at catching
another kind of spam and damn it why
can't I have both you can't you just
need to work your way around it a little
bit and so the idea is that you take
your training data and you train
different algorithms on all of them and
from that you produce a score you get
rid of all of the other underlying data
except for the score produced by these
individual algorithms and you feed it to
a metal earner a meta algorithm which
will actually aggregate them you can use
tree based methods which are really
great at deciding in certain cases you
would want to use certain scores you can
use logistic regression which is also
really popular because then you get some
descriptive feedback as to which of your
algorithms is adding the most weight and
actually can help with algorithm
selection later there is non negative
beta version of logistic regression
where you basically say the coefficient
to each of the scores has to be zero or
greater so you can't have an algorithm
that is so bad it's going in the wrong
direction the best you can do is just
not count it at all and from these you
can kind of ensemble a lot of the
underlying scores and get value out that
way there's also genetic algorithms and
artificial immune systems kind of
similar to the alloy your score that I
mentioned earlier these are processes by
which you learn what is self-similar
what is like the observations you've
seen before and you basically throw up a
very large flag whenever you see
something
is not like yourself also fairly
interesting but there are some good
papers out there I'd recommend reaching
out to them and it's fairly uncommon to
the field I think it's really under
recognized as a technique cool so just
to recap we've got a grid search which
everybody should do it really helps you
key in on the best algorithms as long as
you're not overtraining neural networks
which also deal with class and balance
very well but fortunately beyond the
scope of this talk ensemble models which
help you take the value from different
kinds of models and add them together
genetic algorithms which can identify
dissimilar unlike observations and help
give them a red flag so with that I'm
gonna wrap up actually pretty early so a
lot of the section is left for Q&A as
promised here's the slide deck I have
not put up a new repo for just pi data
so I'm gonna point you towards my strata
talk but the slides are identical take a
picture of it that's the easiest way now
it's a very long link and that's it and
we'll just go ahead and open up for Q&A
thank you question oh yeah so just to
repeat the question if you're using PCA
as an outlier score you want your output
vector to have basically the same shape
as your input vector
but PCA reduces dimensionality how do
you do that
and it's
I'm trying to avoid all of the Matthew
terms which makes it slightly difficult
you will reduce and then you basically
just project back up
so you apply the you go into the smaller
space and they you do the inverse event
you go back into the larger space so you
sort of remove a whole bunch of the
components and then undo that
transformation so that you get this
narrowing and you only remove the
components and contain less information
or less valuable information so you'll
take your top K components if the input
data set has maybe 20 20 variables you
might keep 10 or 15 of the pca
components and the project back up and
that forces the algorithm to kind of
remove a lot of this extraneous
information and it also gives you a
pretty idea for the outlier score does
that help yeah yeah we can dive in a
little bit deeper afterwards but I don't
want to get all white 40 cool any other
questions
oh yeah so similar question for neural
networks you'll want to create a
bottleneck when doing the outlier score
and I think the question is why would
you do that and it's slightly
counterintuitive but it adds a lot of
value so I'll dive a little bit deeper
into that so if you had a neural network
where you had the same number of neurons
and every layer and you're just trying
to output the same thing it would be
pretty easy even if you start with
completely random or stochastic or
whatever weights your arm would just
learn to pass whatever it has on to the
next guy on to the next guy and
hopefully ignore the bias weight as well
so pretty similar to PCA if you have a
bottleneck it forces the algorithm to
reduce the dimensionality of the data
because it's trying to pass on thirty
fields but it only has 20 slots so he
needs to figure out the most effective
way of doing that energy feedback and
then you feedback it'll get more and
more effective at doing it but it just
says hey you can't keep everything learn
to keep the most important things and
then project back up from there does
that answer the question yeah up in
front you're showing as part of the
smoke technique where you compute the
data point between two the rare data
points yeah
how does that work if you have high
dimensionality intensity to me that is a
great question and that's one of the
cases where smotes for breaks down so to
repeat the question with smoke you kind
of impute the distance between two
points but in high dimensionality
everything is equidistant or distance
means very little so that's one of the
edge cases where smote is not so great
but in those cases you can also run pca
beforehand or GL RM reduce the
dimensionality create the observation
and then explode your dimensionality
back up so you can always embed into a
lower dimensional space create your
observation and then unembellished X the
smoke paper is actually really easy to
read I'd recommend reaching out to that
directly because it's as academic papers
go it is not awful and it's also free
which I am a big fan of to give just a
rule of thumb in terms of dimensions if
you're gonna start using any of these
techniques like how far down did you
kind of reduce the dimensionality before
you say you smoke yeah that's that's a
great question so the question is if
you're using smoke and you're reducing
dimensionality how far should you go
it's kind of hard there's just some data
says it doesn't make sense for and it's
difficult because every data set has the
correlation is different on all those
kinds of things but if you have twenty
meaningful variables and they all add a
lot of value and you know correlation
all that it's taken care of
smoke probably wouldn't be a great
technique so distance metrics in my
experience start to break down in
assuming that you're traveling in all
reals in five space maybe in six space
so at that point like the distance
between everything is pretty difficult
that being said sometimes you get lucky
and there's one dimension one or two
dimensions that the outlier observations
will sort of cluster around so it's hard
I'm giving a non-answer and it's hard to
give a real answer but it's sort of the
proof is in the pudding smote is a very
heuristic process and fortunately
there's a couple of packages that
implement it so it'd be easier to just
add it in as a future and see whether or
not it adds value and then think about
the theoretical a whole lot because it's
just one technique there's not a lot of
theoretical underpinnings for but it
does add a fair amount of value does
that answer the question yes cool
I get the lady in the bluish purplish
shirt yeah yeah yeah blue purple that
are
yeah reattach the Department of Commerce
get more data no that's that's good to
tree based methods are also really great
and I haven't mentioned them here
because they're pretty common and that's
just sort of starting but if you have a
smaller data set I would argue actually
just build a decision tree particularly
if it's we're talking about not very
narrow or not very wide or not very long
yeah so if it's not very long trees work
well neural networks take unfortunately
a little bit longer the interpolating is
really great because if you have if you
have 400 observations and you have a one
percent occurrence rate of the rare
label that means you've got four labels
I would argue rethinking whether an
algorithm is an appropriate approach
without gathering more data but if it's
a little bit closer smoke can help boost
up those observations as long as you
have enough to interpolate from and
that's also kind of a non-answer but I
would just avoid neural networks if it's
wide as well you can try glr em it might
actually add a lot of value because then
you're getting closer to a square at
least but it's just sort of trial and
error but if it helps in the back I love
the algorithm but what use it
yeah the question is I would like to use
GL RM what do i download and begin sales
pitch h2o I believe has it as of a few
releases ago and I quite like it again
HBO isn't great for smaller data sets so
there's a couple of benchmarks that were
poorly conducted and I'll give that as
an Asterix where people said that
different things were faster than h2o
and it's like a highly distributed
algorithm so it takes time to distribute
so you pay the multi processing overhead
all of those kinds of things but their
dealer and the competition is pretty
great and it's worked pretty smoothly so
I like it as a first pass I believe
there's also a lesser working model that
is our has one that I don't think is
maintained and spark has an
implementation that I don't know if this
part of course bark or not does that I
have not I need to learn more about
Julia but PI data so cool I think
there's another question back there
the information was in the hundreds or
thousands or use it
oh yeah so we did it direct off sorry to
repeat the question what was the space
they were and for the input and output
layers for the neural network
auto-encoder
I've seen it work we've played with the
number of features because not
everything adds value obviously I've
seen it work with tens the one that we
were using was in the low hundreds so
good amount of data but there was high
correlation in that data set and also
there was a few fields that there were
one or two fields that had four or five
thousand levels which was the main thing
that we're trying to get out so it's
high variance but if nothing else you
can always just subset to the real
valued observation or the real value
variables and then do PCA directly I'd
recommend that as a good first step and
then if you still kind of want to if you
have a field that has a lot of
information and you want to include it
but you don't really want to deal with
encoding then gia I'm is good a great
example of that that's actually pretty
common is zip codes there are many many
zip codes and there's good demographic
information about each zip code but
there's no real way of containing all of
that so you can run jailer I'm on that
to get zip code level data and then use
that as a join so that you have you know
three or four fields to describe all the
zip code data rather than carrying it
all along with you for all these many
many levels does that answer the
question
that is a good question unfortunately I
wasn't the one doing a lot of this work
directly there are a few and Java that
are actually written in just Java
without much of a framework around them
if you follow up I can actually circle
back and get some of the original
frameworks that we'd use but I have to
look into my notes for that if any last
questions yeah
so instead of adding instead of that
bottleneck and here's your on network
which is a choice that you have to make
if you want to make it so having a view
of adding noise to your data including
that way
that's not a question it's
recommendation yeah how do you mean add
noise I see I just add noise so then you
can learn something anything meaningful
so the network so you keep like a same
number as your input all the way down
but then hope that the bias yeah okay so
to repeat the question basically what
the one that we had earlier is you have
a network that has the same number of
neurons as your input all the way down
and then hope that you just don't
overtrain so it passes all the way and
the bias also adds some information
yeah I think that's that's interesting
but at least on the data skills we're
dealing with it's it's much more gentle
edge to fall off of like oh are we just
overtraining if we don't bottleneck at
all and we looked at it very briefly but
the amount of work that would be
necessary to get that the technique
zeroed in was greater than just creating
a bottleneck and there was no blocker
for creating a bottleneck so we just
went that route it's interesting I've
read a lot of the simulated annealing
papers will take a similar approach but
I haven't gone very far with it I think
there was another one towards the back
maybe how do this is being taught in
schools today creepy hot smooth just
kind of school of hard knocks
that's a great question don't get me
started on like the 12-week 12-month
graduate data science programs I think
some of them are great I think some of
them are not great but it's really
interesting to see what people think is
appropriate for this program because
there's such a large variance in what
those programs teach from like here's
our and some data cleaning stuff - let's
learn a little bit core Hadoop and
streaming and everything in between so I
think some of this is suppose this
course so like grid search a lot of the
first ones of each section are kind of
obvious right so observation waiting
grid search random forests like a lot of
that stuff you'll read in introduction
to statistical learning or elements of
Cisco learning which are the bible's of
many of these graduate programs some of
the undergrad programs as well we use is
L and some of us yeah it's just school
of hard knocks and I think some of this
to be quite blunt is our failure as a
community to just communicate with
ourselves so class and balance is a
really common thing but not many people
talk about it and if you look at other
fields what's a good example so there's
other areas of machine learning like nos
UK has its own book for example and a
lot of machine learning of Python will
have their own books but this is just
one weird area where people are doing a
lot of value and everybody is doing it
but we've yet to really come together
and create a totem or a text or
something that helps communicate it so I
think if that were to occur that would
really help but until then it's kind of
really hard to point at a central list
or agenda that should be communicated to
people who are learning which is part of
the reason actually why I put together
this talk but I hope that answers the
question we've got a minute or two for
anything else any other questions
cool more coffee time well I'll be
around feel free to reach out I hope you
enjoyed the talk